so John carpent is the thing is arguably
one of the best sci-fi movies ever made
it's a film to me that stood the test of
time and this is due to its story
special effects and also its titular
character the thing capable of imitating
any life form it's a creature that can
be a best friend one minute and the most
terrifying thing that you've ever seen
the next what I love about the movie is
that almost every aspect of it has a
mysterious element to it and the idea of
not having all the answers is something
that thematically appears throughout
whether it's the ambiguous ending or the
creature itself we never really feel
like we have all the information and I
think this is something that's helped to
keep the movie as a talking point all
these years later however that's where I
come in I want to spoil it all and try
and give you some answers to what the
creature really is as I think it's such
a fascinating thing to talk about that
is definitely worth a video I've gone
through numerous interviews books comics
and everything that I could find to try
and piece together all the information
that I can on what the creature is
throughout this video I'm gonna be going
through it all to try and explain the
thing and why it's one of the most
dangerous entities in the entire
universe if you enjoy the video please
hit the thumbs up button and also make
sure you subscribe a breakdown say this
every day by the way a huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into the
thing
now before looking back at the 1992
movie I actually want to go to the plan
TV sequel title return of the thing a
nice little play on The Lord of the
Rings books this sequel mini-series was
originally commissioned by the Sci-Fi
channel to take place after the events
of the John cop in a movie on the best
movies never made podcasts the creative
team behind it went into what they
learned about the creature when crafting
their planned work and the scripts are
available to read online if you want to
check them out they said that sci-fi
originally wanted to wipe this like
clean and start afresh which led to some
raised eyebrows the heads at the studio
said they even thought they could have
the thing turn into stuff like a chair
or a plank of wood but the newly onboard
scriptwriters rightly said that ideas
sounded stupid they LED with the idea
that they should definitely go with the
sequel and they started to see
everything that they could find on the
creature looking into it all they saw
what the creature was capable of and the
script outlines that it's the perfect
mimic on every level if the person is
copying has a limp it mimics that if
they have a missing tooth that mimics
that and it makes complete copies of
someone down to a cellular level this is
seen the most in the character Norris
who has a heart effect which is copied
by the creature perfectly eventually
this causes him to pass out though the
cells within him like dormant they're
awakened when they feel attacked by the
electrical paddles now the writer David
Leslie Johnson stated that if a person
had a cold that it would even copy the
virus and this would give it away to
become airborne and infect others in the
commentary for the 2011 film it stated
that the thing has no true form because
it actually exists at a microscopic
level and this is kind of where I want
to start really delving into things I'm
sure you know but just in case you don't
the movie is actually based on the book
who goes there it's a short story that I
think is available on YouTube as an
audio book and it actually narrates some
of the events from the creature's
perspective at some point in that its
true form is listed as being a blue
snake head creature with three red eyes
which I'm sure was terrifying at the
time for people reading it in 1938 it
was actually a competition thrown for
people to draw what they thought the
thing looked like which yes to be fair
that does look quite scary however
sticking with the Cinematic version it
doesn't actually have a specific shape
and it's as formless as a virus is
before fully researching this video I
don't know why but I always thought the
thing as being something that was
basically an alien shapeshifter that
could transform into looking like others
however after doing a deep dive on the
thing I realized that a lot of my
assumptions were in fact wrong instead
of being One Singular being this is
cement's made up of many microscopic
organisms that all come together to form
one whole the best way I can think to
describe it is say a magic right imagine
that you caught the flu it isn't really
one specific part of the flu that you
can pinpoint within you and instead it
spreads out but the virus works together
in unison to cause you to get sick now
imagine the flu could come together look
like something and that it had a
personality that's basically what it is
the thing is a walking talking cold with
an agenda that can consume something and
shift about its molecules in order to
perfectly imitate everything about it
because it's copying your brain on a
genetic level it also takes your
memories thought patterns and everything
that makes you you whether it's faults
in your muscles that cause limping
missing teeth are your gray hairs
everything is copied across perfectly
now if it even touches any of your
bodily fluids like blood or saliva then
it will start consuming and altering
your molecules we see this demonstrated
in the 2011 film with a two-headed
version absorbs the character Adam look
closely and you can see the attack that
it goes for us by putting his and its
mouth together as this gives it away to
access his saliva now from here it sells
can rapidly copy and imitate him
bringing him together into this Grand
organism now when looking up scientific
terms for this the best one I could find
is that it's a colonial organism it's a
really cool term I think and this also
explains why it's so weak to fire fire
burns and destroys things down to a
cellular level which is why it's one of
the only things that are capable of
killing it bullets don't work as it can
shift and alter itself to work around
this and thus it has to be burned in
order to kill it fully and I'm talking
about it being more of a reactive
organism it does have somewhat of an
intelligence to it when it becomes
unified in copying beings it of course
takes their memories and brain patterns
unless it's able to think for itself by
having a sort of hive mind this also
means that it has highly Advanced brains
at its disposal too and if it copied an
alien life form capable of space travel
then it too lends its ability this is
why we catch the Blair thing building
its own spaceship at the end of the
movie because the creatures clearly
copied a life form that was capable of
doing this within our own DNA we of
course have data passed on genetically
that goes through the ancestors in our
family tree this is a similar sort of
thing to the creature with a copying
this data and thus having it within
itself however being like a virus also
means that it has an instinctive side to
it that can be broken apart though the
cells work together it's when they Panic
that they're at their weakest working
mainly on instincts when they're
attacked they tend to resort to what All
Creatures do you which is their own
Survival and this has a lot of downsides
to it and with each of these elements
being self-interested they can actually
cause harm to the others we see this in
the case of Palmer who at one point in
the movie points out Norris's head this
may have been done to shift suspicion
away from him and gain trust but it's
clearly a selfish action that leads to
one of the things deaths I think the
best way to look at it is to view the
thing as being somehow Works in unison
to be at its best when all the cells are
together they carry a great sense of
intelligence because they're working
together to problem solve well I think
this is is because it's clear the things
intelligence depends on its size for
example when it's a fully formed human
it can upright at a tactical level and
also strategize things on the opposite
side of this when it's the size of a
splash of blood its Instinct simply is
to run away we can see that the size of
the creature vastly denotes how much
intelligence it has as when it's like
arms in the 2011 movie they just run
around on the floor whereas when it's
Blair it's creating and building ships
now in this Panic state it will often
pull from its own memory and it's
capable of unleashing any of the forms
that it's copied at any point when it
wants these of course have to be
organisms but it means that it can gain
gigantic teeth tentacles and whatever it
needs in this situation however I think
the things credit's weapon comes from
the fact it sounds paranoid and distrust
amongst those it hasn't been able to
copy the movies have people slowly
starting to turn on each other which
allows the thing to move in the shadows
and make its moves from there much like
a virus its goal is to Simply consume
survive and then go on to spreading to
other beings thus it's constantly
searching out new targets and ways to
keep itself going assimilating and
surviving through this is all that it
cares about this makes it an extremely
dangerous entity running a simulation on
a Blair's working show that it would
take 27 000 hours to take over Earth
this is roughly three years and it would
mean infecting every human animal insect
and form of life on our planet it's
estimate is over 1 trillion life forms
on the planet which shows how much that
would involve imitating a trillion
seconds is 31 000 years giving you a
rough idea of how Grand that scale is
now one thing I love in the book that
unfortunately doesn't make it to the
movie is that the Cam's terrified about
the thing making it to a bird back when
it was written helicopters and planes
weren't as commercially available as
they are today and thus the group of
sketch they said it's going to get into
a bird and fly its way out of there now
when looking at its backstory we
actually know a lot about it from the
2011 film in the behind the scenes they
stay at the ship we see at the start was
actually part of an Interstellar
Expedition that was out in the universe
conducting Zoological studies they
collected a number of different species
from other planets and place them into
pods as part of their cargo or one
planet they came across the thing and
trapped it so that it could be examined
but it managed to break free and it took
over the craft in a desperate move the
pilot crashed the ship and attempt to
kill it and the creature was buried in
the eyes for one hundred thousand years
Peter Watts also wrote a short story
from the thing's perspective in which it
outlined itself as an ambassador that
was traveling throughout the Galaxy to
shape the universe into Being Fit for
purpose that's not considered Canon but
it is an interesting thing to bring up
when discussing the creature anyway that
leads us into the event of the 2011
movie which then goes in the 82 film
before we get to those Doom sequel
spin-offs unfortunately we haven't
really got a canonized version of what
happens after this with the video games
and comic series differing in some ways
the Sci-Fi series also went off in a
different version and if you'd like to
see me break these all down then let me
know in the comments below if you want
more theme content then make sure you
check out our breakdown of the 1982
movie which will be linked on screen
right now I am going to cover the 2011
version as well at some point so make
sure you stay locked so you don't miss
it by the way thanks for clicking the
video I've been poor let's see you next
time you take care peace